un soleil automnal se lève ce mardi 24
novembre sur touahri depuis près d'un
mois aucun visiteur ne peut se rendre
dans le parc zoologique à cause du
second confinement une situation inédite
qui n'a pas l'air de perturber les 1500
animaux du parc rien en particulier pas
de changement déjà au prochain
confinement on n'avait pas vu grand
chose de spécial au niveau du changement
des comportements
non vraiment il s'en fiche un petit peu
nos animaux y font leur petite routine
n'y a pas de problème pour pas de
bouleversement non plus pour les 25 à 30
personnes qui travaillent chaque jour
sur le site
évidemment que la vie continue à thoiry
les animaux a même si elles confinement
il faut continuer de s'en occuper
même s'il ya pas les visiteurs pour
venir les voir il faut les nourrir
nettoyer l'horloge et faire en sorte que
tout aille bien pour eux si le quotidien
des animaux et des soigneurs n'est pas
bousculer les gros changements sont à
observer du côté des allées du parc vide
de monde depuis le 29 octobre après une
belle fréquentation lors de la saison
estivale ce nouveau confinement est un
coup dur pour les recettes et surtout la
programmation du mois de novembre à
novembre est plutôt une période un peu
creuse maintenant depuis trois ans
maintenant on a lancé le festival et
l'indien qui nous permet justement de
deug de toucher un public un peu plus
large sur l'hiver et moi météo dépendons
puisque la balade se prolonge en début
de soirée avec des illuminations
féeriques dans les jardins du château
la direction du zoo espère pouvoir
recommencer le festival des lumières
d'ici la fin de l'année si le
gouvernement le permet en attendant le
parc vous propose de suivre le quotidien
des animaux depuis votre canapé sur ces
réseaux sociaux